Republican senator Lindsey Graham was
again overcome with emotion on
television you might remember last week
he was crying about the uh pending
arrest of Donald Trump he was on Fox
news last night begging people send
Trump money why you need to send a
billionaire money I don't even
understand but here is Lindsay again oh
this is starting to get a little bit
embarrassing I'm sorry I'm so upset but
please help president Trump if you could
afford five or ten bucks if you can't
afford a dollar fine just pray if you
make 28 grand a year if you can throw
five bucks at this billionaire to help
him please make sure you vote as early
as you can in your state don't risk
anything oh now early voting is good huh
I think anymore vote as soon as you can
pray for this country pray for this
President and if you got any money to
give give it
lindsaygram.com it doesn't go to me it
goes to helping this President and
taking back the Senate yep then he
continues and he says he set up a
website for Trump it's all crazy three
great Senate pickup opportunities to
give us the Senate back in 2024 three uh
Democrats in deep red states that are up
in 2024 we can take back the Senate and
president Trump could get a second term
to finish out his agenda there's a lot
of love in the streets but love ain't
gonna do it pal they're trying to ruin
this country they're trying to destroy
president Trump tonight I have set up a
website I don't get one damn Penny but I
want you to give money tonight to help
president Trump yeah he's raised eight
million remember to help him what are
you donating to Trump's campaign are you
donating to Trump's primary campaign is
it money for the general is it money
that is for Trump's legal defense like
what what are you donating to Lindsay
ever since this legal garbage started
don't stop now seventy percent of the
money you give tonight goes to help
president Trump 30 percent will help
take back the Senate to help him do what
he's got a chance to pick up three
Senate seats in very red States held by
democrats and I want to wake up after
the election in 2024 with the Republican
house or Republican Senate and Donald
Trump raised his right hand swearing to
be the president of the United States
that we need you are not helpless out
there folks yeah really a dystopian
vision and if you're saying didn't
didn't Lindsay just do this yes here is
Lindsay last week crying on Fox news
about the indictment how do you do it
you take a well if you got a pile of
crap and you chop it up 34 times it's
still a pile of crap it's duplicious
charging they're trying to smear the guy
they're trying to take cases that nobody
else would take and resurrect them this
is literally legal Voodoo yeah so the
grift is fully back and Lindsay is
trying to take charge of it so there are
of course so many questions here first
of all if Trump's a billionaire why does
he constantly need money for everything
he needs money because of desanctus and
he needs money because of Joe Biden and
he needs money because of Alvin Bragg
and this is what's the money for is it
for the campaign legal defense Fund in
this case Lindsay is saying for every
dollar you give through Lindsay's
website
Trump gets 70 cents and then 30 cents go
to some kind of General Pool for Senate
re-election campaigns or something like
that this is Lindsay trying to get
credit for bringing money in
fundamentally and as usual Trump likes
his followers to the extent that they're
useful and he went to them and grifted
them after the 2020 election saying oh
we're going to file all these lawsuits
and forensic Audits and recounts and it
all went nowhere nowhere but he grifted
people who statistically don't really
have the money to be giving money to
Trump for this nonsense he grifted them
to the tune of millions tens of millions
I believe it was and now they're trying
to do it again so my thought is save
your money save your money maybe put it
in a savings account maybe get an index
fund account going maybe put it in a 529
if there's a kid who at some point might
need an education and don't give the
money to trump it just doesn't seem like
the most useful use of funds and this is
me advising people who don't like me but
I don't want to see you grifted all
right